Just one or two questions I have a gay
male.
I want to say thank you for speaking the
truth.
Absolutely ballistic.
The next two questions I want to get
your social contract and the safe space
that university I turned to push on us
as well as what your view on this whole
white privilege thing is that
universities like unt Rogerson,
Gail,
all these other universities in terms of
crandall?
No.
I think the idea of white privilege is
absolutely reprehensible
and it's not because people aren't
traveling.
You know we have all sorts of privileges
and most people have privileges of all
sorts and you should be grateful for
your privileges and work to deserve
them,
I would say,
but the idea that you can target an
ethnic group with a collective crime
regardless of the specific innocence or
guilt of the constituent elements of
that group.
There is absolutely nothing that's more
racist than not.
It's absolutely
boring.
I can't.
You're not.
If you.
If you really want to know more about
that sort of thing,
you should read about the Kulaks in the.
In the Soviet Union,
in the 19 twenties,
k,
U L A,
s because they were.
They were farmers who were very
productive.
They were the most productive element of
the agricultural strata in,
in Russia,
and they were virtually all killed or
raped and robbed by the collectivists
who insisted that because they showed
signs.